philia transition for the jam when
you're at Leeper and put their hand up
like throw it go go get it you know a
little bit about that don't ya back in
the day Adelphia steals it from under
the rim jake milk out desire smith died
here somehow another to hand stuff and
sterling Brown when you've been in the
league like sterling Brown my guess is
you have to control the same song for
sure if you can you'll see the
difference in guys that's played some
NBA games they have guys that that not
eyeballs on the best defender maybe in
the n-c-double-a last year black there
by Billy here comes I Spit Jesse's badly
there hell with another rebound
here's Eyre Smith do you going up top
yep I'm pretty good I'm solid I'm not
great yeah that where I want to be with
this right where he wants to be in
that's throwing it down
that's what dunkers do they you see what
that hand goes up throw it up there he
wants it your spider can be backdoor cut
easy hops to to play the way that
Milwaukee knows he could play yeah and
Philly by the way it closed on a NATO
run and there's no golf pellet can see
probes waste to the last second and he
knows I just do it anywhere by the
square not the rim by the square do you
think his mom certainly could shoot he's
the son of Hall of Famer Nancy Lieberman
Johnny Hamilton got the rejection but
sire Smith with the putback off glass
you shoot the ball and don't worry about
everything else
look there's eye ear Smith - PJ Dozier
[Applause]
and now we've got a dunk contest it
feels like going on here because I hear
Milton with a greatness see the perfect
pass and as a dunker four-point game
3:25 to go Highsmith to the corner
desire Smith the experience he added
Virginia helped him have success and
Iowa State
the Celtics got their first points of
the night moving toward the stores table
to check in that's a matchup taco fall
and imagine our hard-working physical
position lists rotated and compensatory
razors
three minutes left
zyre Smith hits from outside Evans with
the mr. Chauhan has been up and down in
the NBA from the G League to the NBA
played for the Clippers for a bit
there's a three-point of 10x there for
shame nope
[Music]
here's our Smith former first rounder
gets that mathmatics drumstick to
patiently for the and gentlemen and
audience behind us Xavier Smith gets
that one to balling so here it gets the
flare screen uses the body the hang time
off the glass
you show offensive so some offensive
points that you want to bake them
sometimes you just kind of have to do
scrap it on to the next steel the other
ways I your spit mrs. put back with my
Hankins is put back attend Highsmith was
like yo man yo yeah when your team
here's how your Smith and he takes out
for the time
daya fines Komachi Komachi with the hook
shot
[Applause]
65 to 54
thanks desire Smith & Company Brett
brown is also in the house full of
philly and tie your Smith is a great
such a creature of habit that that has
affected the Advil despite all that Russ
will be more than than fine as
eventually there's a base out there
Bible
taps it away from him and Philly on the
run another rebound for OKC he's right
over there in front of all the Pistons
and Drummond and canard and Jackson are
sitting they probably said something
funny to get him smiling top of the key
three is builder Smith they went on to
the screen Smith took advantage is it
along toward the 76ers setting a screen
right there to free of Shia Tire Smith
lost the handle got it back and said he
went over a 7 foot 4 inch individual
tire Smith oh I thought he was going to
did he lose that or did he intend to do
a layin like that Dozier had the shot
altered by Hernandez and it's missed 15
feet I've seen a growth offensively with
him and he just makes things happen he
anticipates them hunting on the
defensive and he gives it up for Jones
showing his range from three certainly a
great reputation as a defensive player
coming out of Oregon second in history
in school history of blondes and I
didn't understand that and you know I
was doing my own thing in college and
help that that preconceived notion which
was just dead wrong signed a two-way
deal with the Sixers back in January I
got waived and late June he comes now to
throw it again that would have been a
really scary squad corner try no good
for Alban jr. Smith the head of the pack
with the right hand from the left side
for the Timberwolves the mark I know you
will note as well that the Ohio Valley
Conference is quite well represented
here at summer league this year don't
know what a big red ball did you just go
out there why are you thinking waited
basketball or inflatable I want a real
basketball
with everybody what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content